I want something and he said this work
turns players into Kings and it dawned
on me for a long time what the
expression made for years I told her
around Hollywood for years I told her on
Hollywood like everybody else tiptoes
around Hollywood I didn't want to piss
nobody off I didn't really want to ask
some more money I didn't want to do this
and then one day you snapped something
really happens in your brain and you
cover all your bases and you work hard
but it's called sacrifice hmm you know I
don't think people especially people
like Lee know what sacrifices sacrifice
is a big word to get to the next level I
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody tells you
you have a mom Steve some on campus your
mom a lot
yes thank God I should dad on thank God
your brothers your siblings yeah where
do they live 3,000 miles away that
sacrifice
absolutely you don't need this you don't
need on the mother that could be sitting
between the Jew and a Cuban getting
tormented in [ __ ] North Hollywood
California to go to the county store to
pick up a check for $15 absolutely your
parents man your grandparents migrated
here to this country for you to be a
benefit yeah your brother became a
dentist I'm not putting you down
now you're right on saying this but you
sacrifice a day literally you slept with
fat-sucking James and his apartment
smelling his fat [ __ ] feet for an ass
here which one worse than those Jews on
the blade I'd have a guard I just a bus
for 16 another horrifies and a calf Isis
really job to hold for Christmas yeah
and I'm working at a Hollywood gym
night-night chest it bothers me that
nobody understands that you know I had a
dear friend died three weeks ago not
dear it was a friendship that I loved
the daily and alcohol and mental health
took her somewhere else it's a very sad
thing I had to block her on my phone
yeah so I'm not gonna sit here and tell
you you know she was my best friend well
had a black world my phone I got too
many things in my life either be calling
me 18 times on stage
Frank to break my [ __ ] balls and I
got a little slack for it but I go a
little moral this week okay
but I also remember when these people
came from these people move to add to
Colorado to Los Angeles in the group
they went 15 deep by the Houston Texas
but nobody wanted to sacrifice mmm
didn't want to sacrifice the most
important things for the most important
thing the random why are you here yeah
you know before I go and stay Saturday
night there was these great funny guys
like a man we brought your reefer we
brought you this where we go in Thailand
I know I can't [ __ ] go nowhere
I got a 5:45 flight to New York and then
I can't you call your wife and put it
off for Vegas I told my god this is
nothing to do with my wife don't give a
[ __ ] about my wife this has to do with
me because I got it that means I got to
fly at 12:00 to get home at 6:00 I'm not
gonna be on my kid plus I got an
audition Monday morning plan you know oh
no I'm just gonna steam and get off the
plane and go to CBS Radford and after I
stayed out with [ __ ] people smoking
dope and talking about nothing Frank
because at the end of the day that's
what you do is talk about you and I did
this I wasted that time the [ __ ] 30
years I'm not gonna sit here and get on
a high horse and tell you none another
no I've wasted enough sup in time but in
this town once I took control of me now
I always sacrificed yeah I made the
biggest sacrifice I looked at a
five-year-old little girl one day in the
park and I told her that I'm really
thinking of going away for a while but I
think it would be better and she spit in
my face my daughter my daughter at 27
years old clown when I told her about my
dream she spit in my face on a bicycle
and that was too big a sacrifice I made
I made the sacrifice to say I'll give up
my daughter to do something with my life
okay and then I came here and while
these people were all drinking early
yeah even though I was a junkie coke
fiend I could hold off till 11:30 12:00
and I remember you doing late night s
and being up call me once because you
found something on the breakdowns you
were waking up early going over the
breakdowns on her own I was an animal
and I didn't go to weddings I didn't go
to wakes
cuz I didn't do a lot of things yeah and
I'm sure I'm sure along the way I
discipline
a lot of people yeah because I didn't
attend their wedding or whatever
function they had because they had a
party you know when this changed it's
because my head chains hmm explain that
my head changed it's that you realize
but this happened way before mercy this
was happening two years before I met Lee
okay yeah I always sacrificed let's get
something wrong yeah you're always
paying is I always sacrifice I sacrifice
holidays let me tell you something this
weekend when I went home and I saw my
friends and I saw like Steven villo and
Alan Pasquale and [ __ ] Carlos and
they both see it I realized something
that yes I'm very happy idea but I'm
very lonely out here yeah they're a
different type of breed this is what
home is all about I agree with you and I
can't replace that their company the new
wooden word Halloween in second grade
remember where your house smelled like
on a Sunday yeah you can replace that so
I see all these guys and when I got on
the plan I go that's what I sacrifice
and don't get me wrong I made a lot of
mistakes to force myself to leave there
there's a subtle way I wanted to leave
there like I couldn't I was embarrassed
I wouldn't ever became anything there I
knew I had the same feeling but the
sacrifice I had was to not to lose my
friends to not have them in my life
Timmy Holloway those type of people the
wedding should mr. Burt wedding is the
person in the bar so I'm doing all that
[ __ ] and so that was the first sacrifice
I made then I sacrificed my relationship
my daughter I knew when I got in that
call and I left both I wasn't coming
back and even my heart I knew that I
would just get in trouble that I would
just end up a bad position there and it
was time for me to cleanse myself of all
that in this relationships that I prayed
to God I wanted to prove to her that I
was worth something the long-term goal
the liquor than the short-term
satisfaction absolutely the secret to
success is delaying gratification and
you know if you stayed there you
couldn't be the person you would value
so then you wanted to do something with
your life to show her how much you
really do love her that's what I'm
getting is coming you got to do that
sometimes it was it was [ __ ] real
like it was just something
that you know I sacrifice a remote you
know Josh walk dear friend of mine
all those years had parties on cyanides
with his family and Scott wolf and all
these other actors and the singers from
the Counting Crows that didn't mean
anything to me how was it the Communists
you know what I had to get $50 so I'm
gonna do Felipe's room and then get to
my comedy store for my 11:45 on Saturday
and Hannah you sacrificed and I party
I'm not gonna lie to you that but he was
my party I made my auditions I took care
of things I you know I I took care of
things the best I could
yeah after I got off the coke like in
2009 before I married Terry is where
this came this picture became clearer to
me that I even had a sacrifice more mmm
like I had a sacrifice more like I went
to Weight Watchers I joined the karate
with the brothers in 2007 I was going I
was promised for I was 380 when I walked
in there and I'm it was horse stances
and my knees would [ __ ] bird
they would make you do these dragon
stances when you dragged one foot and
kneel on this one I don't have to go
home for two bags of [ __ ] ice on my
knees but I knew that these were little
sacrifices I had to get make to get to
where I want to be it was the weirdest
[ __ ] thing well that was that just
like an intuition that you had I kind of
went bad about a lot of days I went back
to how successful I was when I attended
karate from the age of six to the ages
of fifteen then while you did it your
whole childhood yeah well I dropped out
of karate was when I got left back in
the seventh grade mind body soul that
reconfirmed everything so I knew for me
to get back to my mental state I had to
pick a martial art and look for a temple
school I couldn't find one so the best
kept secret in Hollywood was this guy
this uh style of kungfu
mixed with tempo the Hawaiian tempo it
just made me get loose hmm I just went
to get my day started I said I and I
said to myself for me to do this and
be successful nothing could take the
place so this wasn't picking up an
envelope yes
Beltre found her I went back to the war
of art the art of war whatever that book
is I went back to if I'm not doing
something good to me I'm in the house
writing and there's no resistance the
only way I can get out of kung-fu is if
I'm making money well it's something to
make money not to meet somebody about a
script everything I must have way
consumed everything getting pushback
everything gets pushed back for this
nothing is as important and I started
with that if I could do it just on
Mondays then I would go Mondays and
Tuesdays that was on the road that so I
would go three days a week by Friday my
knees would be swollen then I pop them
one knee and I got knee surgery and I
went away you know but you sacrificed so
many little things along the way there
was a lot of times yes I want to go me
favor with this guy and go get
sandwiches and you don't do that anymore
because that time is for writing now
yeah and you know that time is dictated
to writing that's what that time is
about you know tonight after dinner for
about 35 minutes I always go and I look
over the book that's great and I write
two sentences and even though I wanna
sit there with my wife and watch World
News Tonight there's not no world news
tonight that's going to change my life
any more exacting but it's about Russia
or science stupid that's not going to do
anything at all to me but it's amazing
that people think they're really gonna
get ahead in this life without making
sacrifices it drives me crazy yeah it
drives me crazy how you have to you know
what yes or not and paper life is Monday
through Friday well that's a great
thought that's a great [ __ ] thought
that's a great thought but when you're
44 you're gonna find yourself $30,000 in
credit card debt yeah and a fixed
[ __ ] income if you go ten if you get
a flat tire you're done for the [ __ ]
month because you leave your credit
cards just enough room for emergencies
with all that [ __ ] and how do you know
because it happened to me yeah these 9
to 5 [ __ ]
the ages of 20 to 35 unless you're
making a lot of [ __ ] loot there's no
nine-to-five in my world I understand
that [ __ ] you know and again that's what
I had to learn the hard way
all right you know saying those are the
things that we think society they're
learning you know when you're first
training and your job member you work
Saturdays it sucks when you're a kid it
sucks working salaries and your kid
especially you like going out on Friday
night and drinking some vodka tonics and
waking up hungover late to your house
it's Sox waking up in your the [ __ ] a
junior in high school to go sell paint
work is [ __ ] fun target in sight or
something yeah it's uh continue for a
while you young and you're a football
friend you like well never work on
Sundays well think again [ __ ]
that shit's got a sale pretty [ __ ]
soon you know especially in high school
like those jobs you can get in high
school I worked at a CVS I worked at a
movie theater you have to be there early
what about I can't imagine starbug
working at a coffee place we have to be
there by like what 3:00 in the morning
they open up this one here 4:30 to drive
door opens Wow so what what tell
anything people get it open any 45 Oh
Mike trying on the buttons on yeah but
you figure you're out of there by 10:00
if you're a student that's a sacrifice
if you're but if you're a student like
you should be busy all the time yeah
like if you're a student a real student
and you're putting yourself through or
you have a couple loans and your parents
are helping you you gotta have a job I
work at Starbucks and for the [ __ ]
and what are you sacrificing your stupid
night life it's amazing how you get the
one puzzle piece and it makes other ones
fall in line rather flex ball falls in
line because now you can't make as many
dumb decisions because now you have the
responsibility being up early all those
things start to change your life you get
karate down and then your body starts
getting stronger then your mind gets
stronger it all works together as a
moment it's so weird because you'll say
to yourself well I really can't do that
because this is what I do on those days
it's also you like you don't want doing
what I was doing
bring me anything yeah